brian a las vegas man is left to plan
not only one funeral but three he spoke
to victoria saha and how in just a blink
of an eye covid took his family away
32 year old jason rose has dealt with
more loss in the last week than most
people do in a lifetime he is struggling
to find ways to come to terms with the
loss of his grandfather grandmother and
mother he says it's just a reminder of
how quickly this virus can take away
lives rose's grandparents and mother
went into the hospital together last
week by friday they had all died his
mother was a high risk dialysis patient
and was going through dialysis every day
at home she worried the side effects of
the vaccine would do more harm than good
his grandparents were hoping faith would
get them through this pandemic it's
unclear how they contracted the virus
but now rose is left to pick up the
pieces
my grandpa passed on tuesday
this past tuesday
and then you know my grandma passed away
thursday and then my mom passed away
friday morning to be honest i'd rather
have been me you know like that's how
much i love my family rose also dealt
with covid earlier this summer and was
unvaccinated he says he is more inclined
to get the vaccine now
rose is planning funeral services and is
trying to save the home his mother
bought 22 years ago her dying wish was
to hold on to that house he has set up a
gofundme in hopes to get help it's on
our website at 8newsnow.com victoria
saha 8 news now